guess we're home who the hell are you  guys here's the nutshell I'm a psychic  he is a sympathetic pooper  we're grown men real pubes the mustache  is spectacular from my lip to God's ear  what's wrong with you two  lassies saying thanks ghost not  necessarily go let's probably ghosts you  really want to help just be the crow men  that you are can you stand this is a  lassie mystery  the stakes are possibly life and death  between the need my collection of  mustaches in order to snoop around  undetected classy oh my gosh  James Shawn Spencer this is my partner  leggo my eggo no ding-dong-ditch  nope Norman brown butter from now water  I'd do the nickname no absolutely not we  can't just stop doing bits we've been  doing for 10 years wavered pick up  website I see it  I so turned on right now  I'm going to be honest with you that  title sounds like you made it up right  this second  go ahead guys knock it up something get  that dead Hannah wait for me Sean  you